les français rêvent de quiétude de
amoureuse selon un sondage ifop réalisé
à l'occasion de la saint valentin les
fantasmes de nos concitoyens
apparaissent plutôt raisonnable les
français et les françaises restent en
effet de s'en lasser tendrement sous les
cocotiers devant un coucher de soleil
attendre un ou une partenaire plutôt
expérimenté dans un lit à baldaquin ou
beaucoup plus facilement sous la douche
les français l'amour et patrice
romedenne cherchez l'erreur nous sommes
censés vous parler d'amour dans l'océan
d'un coucher de soleil et d'un palier
car c'est à ce genre de fantasme carte
postale que rêve 8 français sur 10
passons à l'intérieur si vous le voulez
bien pour y apprendre que 40% d'entre
nous nos jure que par le
porte-jarretelles la guêpière ou le
string notre libido aussi satisfaite
reste à passer à l'acte c'est pas une
question de vieux simpson sentiment
c'est pas vraiment ce qui ressort du
sondage madame comme dirait l'autre il y
à des endroits pour ça alors allons-y
75% d'entre nous plébiscitent les
sous-bois et le lit mais pas n'importe
quel dans un lit à baldaquin
certainement quelque chose
exceptionnelle c'est on revient en
arrière au xviiie siècle et je pense que
ça doit pas être désagréable
suivent de près la douche et un autre
grand cliché de la qualité des thèses
sur la plage
si abbas un vrai j'ai un peu pudique ans
moi je fais l'amour dans une voiture on
voit debout donne quand j'en ai envie
monsieur fait sans doute partie des 60 %
de français qui jugent l'infidélité
néfastes mais pas dramatique mais
monsieur irait sans doute moins souvent
au bois s'il ressembler à paul newman
robert redford ou kevin costner vos
préférés et mesdames
quant à vous messieurs si vous aviez le
choix sophie marceau emmanuelle béart et
isabelle adjani vous comblerez mais vous
n'avez pas le choix
alors vous rêvez un rêve en forme de
femmes mûres épanouie 78 % de candidats
vous rêvez d'une brune mystérieuse la
voilà du jeune ingénue romantique elle
est à vous ou encore d'une sportive
dynamique
allez-y servez vous rêvez et surtout
n'oubliez pas de vous réveiller
j'arrive j'arrive